okay count you in five four three two
hello everybody and welcome to the h3
podcast experience also known as the
correct opinions own disagree with the
opinions here take a you might want to
think twice because these are infallible
highly uninformed and 100% correct all
the time couldn't possibly be wrong yet
it's not an option it's not not in this
cell with me is the beautiful talented
and very blue ela Klein round of
applause what else and a CEO
yeah and CEO of course thank you to
today's sponsors kaptara equipped and
the undies and for all of our loyal fans
and listeners there is a new h3 h3 video
out on our channel h3h3 productions so I
hope you enjoy that check it out please
enjoy it today we've got a lot to get to
I've got a new mic how do I sound today
we've got the Shane Jake documentary I
want to talk a little bit about that
Bill Cosby has started a new sitcom in
which he goes to prison which is a
really I'm really looking forward to
that's on NBC premieres this fall at 8
p.m. looking forward to Bill Cosby goes
to prison we've also got Drake and
Millie Bobby Brown have been raising
eyebrows with their salacious I feel
like that's over the top interesting
relationship and much much more
oh welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
experience all right thanks for coming
everyone we really we got the best we
got the best stuff here to talk about so
from the top Shane and Jake Shane Dawson
is the king of YouTube yeah these past
couple of I want pretty crazy he's been
kind of the king of YouTube for like
past year or something but these whole
documentary and series have just been
over the over the top like can you pull
up his channel I want to show you the
views that
got there but right now he has just come
out with a Jake Paul documentary called
inside the mind of Jake Paul when he
tries to understand really what's going
on with that guy and I'm intrigued let's
see a little is here look look at all of
his recent views why does that look so
low-quality
is that just part of the thing 16
million 14 million 18 24 million I mean
this is just this is average yeah this
is insane
this is like new level [ __ ] so anyway
his new documentary about Jake falls out
look at this I loved this
Jake's response to part one was number
two trending with 2.2 million views in
two days and Shane's video with 10
million views in one day wasn't on
trending I don't
damn what the hell what's the logic how
do you trend Jake Paul's response video
I don't know why can they just fix the
trending page it's like it's just not a
trending page it's not and if it is
curated why do they keep training Jake
Paul yeah if there's really no good
explanation for why this would be there
not that one it literally is
counterintuitive
yeah their response isn't what's
trending it's the topic itself it's just
it's it's maddening but regardless they
took the crutch of it is that he's
trying to see if Jake Paul's a sociopath
and I personally don't think that Jake
Paul's a sociopath I mean that's a tall
claim but then it takes this twist where
he's like well maybe he's a brother
Logan is the sociopath and it's about
him living in the shadow of his brother
which is a really interesting twist and
I definitely can see that I could see
that yeah I can see that for sure so I
am looking forward to seeing how this
series unveils but there was by the way
I think Logan was blindsided by the
whole thing because Jake and his video
was like I knew it was about sociopathy
and
he's like I'm not a sociopath so come
make this documentary about me he's like
it's gonna be a good PR for me [ __ ] the
Logan I think was blindsided that he was
all the sudden coming under the
magnifying lens and he just tweeted out
this morning this I really didn't want
to but I feel compelled to give my
thoughts on Shane series this far Blair
and then Shane actually responded a
surprise extended finale which is a
shame really don't give a [ __ ] he's
ready but anyway the really intriguing
thing for me and I am I am the I'm
intrigued you know I'm I'm glued to the
set here in fact Shane has given a lot
of youtubers hope kind of with how his
channel just turns second yeah well for
a long time he was a guy that just
taste-tested fast food yeah and they did
it for so long I don't know what he was
doing before that that was probably he
did like sketches and she had I don't
know he's not he has two channels he's
been kind of like been around forever
and doing all kinds of different content
but he was like just eating food for a
long yeah but he likes it slugged
through it found his voice yeah and he
really he's got this second wind that's
unbelievable
it's really cool I really like the style
of the document innovative it's fresh
it's really well edit yeah I don't know
who's editing that I'm sure Shane is
probably sitting there a lot with editor
but then editing yeah absolutely bananas
he wears the same shirt in every video I
don't think so
well I don't know if it's the same sir
but either that or he's like Doug funny
and he's got like you know you never
done but he's like and we're doing named
outfit every day and but then there's a
episode where he walks in the closet and
he just has like morning same outfit he
wears the same shirt god bless his soul
you know but hey but there was one
moment here that really broke my heart
there was a moment in the new episode
that really broke my heart as a fan as a
call I want to say colleague but maybe
an associate you could say as
who's had him here a guest on our
podcast yeah it really broke my heart
so here it is I'm really gonna talk
about this if you notice anything here
I've gotta miss the time stamp for
Christ's sake see if you notice anything
here okay as he's talking about this
okay listen closely my friends
you're all gonna really this is really
upsetting podcast on a podcast damn
no we're smitten Shane breaking my heart
Shane you're breakin my heart go and
watch podcast on a podcast Shane
family this is my godfather impression
what family you come in my house you sit
across the table from me what I could no
respect to disrespect you so much they
you come on a podcast we you have a
podcast in my mind it sounds like a
perfect Italian Godfather impression
spot on she never gets the family and
you breaking my heart
no it's half Russian she you're breaking
my heart on a podcast
anyway god bless him I'm not upset I
just thought it was funny I just thought
it was a funny opportunity to do my well
traveled well seasoned Godfather
not one in the pocket for a while here
at the office yeah I'm working on that
eye Godfather accent for a long time so
did you change your mind by jakub or
anything no I never thought I kind of
always suspected that Jake deep down
isn't a bad guy mm-hmm I had that
impression when I sat here with him and
I thought you know because I I had a
conversation with him outside off-camera
and I was like dude tell me straight
good we were walking to the bathroom
together and I was like and this was
during their heyday when they were
really competitive I was like tell me
hey yeah do you how are you guys cuz it
seems really toxic and he's and he said
honestly it's really bad we honestly
really hate each other
you know he told me that in complete
earnestness off-camera in the hallway
he's like it's really bad honestly you
can tell that they're complete
competitive its mentality is real well
apparently Logan actually really [ __ ]
Jake's ex-girlfriend
like for real and then made like a diss
track about it but Jake was like dude
like like act like I know that's like
good for views but that actually really
hurts my feelings
mm-hmm you know like these guys are
[ __ ] twisted yeah but apparently Jake
actually gets into a lot of this stuff
so I'm looking for that but if you can
hit me with that music one more time
Shane I bring you one here we talk we
sit across the tip this is getting
better
Shane what I bring you here you sit
across the table for me we talk we have
a good time what do I do
Heelys give me the crickets moving on
Bill Cosby there's a new sitcom coming
up on NBC which is a really ballsy play
on their part
Bill Cosby goes to prison for sexual
assault I was like wow that's a really
edgy idea wait hold on it's not a sitcom
Bill Cosby in handcuffs after getting
over three years in prison for 2004 rape
wait I thought this oh man I thought it
was just a sitcom yeah
welcome to Papa's house aka prison the
clink
is that crazy at the same wait handcuffs
dude it is the weirdest timeline can we
just reflect on the fact that 81 year
old Bill Cosby worth four hundred
million dollars mm-hmm America's most
beloved entertainer jell-o eaten coke
sip and Bill Cosby is going up just
America I was like yeah it's going to
prison at 81 years old for rape
that's the weirdest timeline imaginable
mm-hmm oh my god
he was convicted in April of drugging
and sexually assaulting Andre constand
who testified that Cosby violated her at
his Pennsylvania home in 2004 after she
came to him for career advice she was
sentenced to 3 to 10 years for sexual
assault
he has to register as a sex offender
he's classified as a sexually violent
predator online and they need to inform
all their neighbors that a sexually
violent predator lives in the area
that's a lifetime registration although
I don't think his life is gonna be that
much longer
81 in prison he's in general population
- a lot of people are like oh he's gonna
get
preferential treatment listen to this
he's in general population and he's so
famous you know what they're doing
because when he talks to his wife in
prison they have speaker phones and like
everyone around can hear oh is that yeah
it's all monitored cuz it's a [ __ ]
prison
you know I mean they always in the
movies so everyone can hear yeah okay
near or if you're the police if you're
working there you're listening to what
they're talking about yeah and so people
are paying they want to know everything
he's talking about with his wife
what saw all these tabloids are
publishing everything he's talking about
with his wife they can do that well
that's how they found out I mean prop no
I'm sure it's probably illegal but
people are getting paid here's some of
the anecdotes that came out of those
phone conversations in a phone call with
his wife Cosby recounted that a hot dog
bun was thrown at his face Cosby who is
legally blind said he fell down a flight
of stairs because he wasn't being guided
and was without his cane which was
apparently taken away along with his
shoelaces by correctional officers over
fears that he may harm himself
Cosby told his wife grabbed the
checkbook and hire anyone and everyone
who could get him out as soon as
possible this [ __ ] worth 400
million bucks and that money cannot save
him this article says he said I think
I'll harm myself no the officials think
he'll harm himself
I mean Oh Cosby tells wife officials oh
he he told his wife though officials
think I'll harm myself because they took
away his cane and his shoelaces as I
understand this normal hmm but god damn
can you imagine you're just like in
prison and you're like oh it's Bill
Cosby no hey Bill oh and here's another
great one his first meal
in prison vanilla pudding you put the
pudding and the you put the hot dog mud
in the face of the pudding at the mouth
really showing off your impressions is
the impression experienced agency [ __ ]
profession experience Hey but che how
could he do this to me
you put the pudding you came here I gave
you pudding if you said a podcast how am
i doing impression 10 anime crossovers
right there so I think it's so pathetic
so weird
people are throwing hot dog buns at his
face like like that's maybe the biggest
fall from grace of all time like
Shakespeare the Greek mythology have
stories of from king to peasant I mean
this is a literal story of being Bill
Cosby beloved powerful rich beyond
imagination to inmates
throwing hot dog stale hot dog buns at
your face well the guy was a [ __ ]
prolific predator yeah the stories of
what that guy did it was really remark I
mean really astounding stuff actually
have some clips this one is really
incredible it's a clip of from his old
show The Cosby Show beloved by all where
he talks about he's doing a barbecue and
he's like and his wife was like isn't it
so nice how everyone's getting along
after their fighting and he goes hey
it's it's the secret is my barbecue
sauce she's like oh you're kidding he's
like oh dead serious and he like doesn't
smile his face is like deadpan he's
sinister sounding and he continues he
goes
oh no I'm dead serious you ever noticed
when you have my barbecue sauce that
everyone gets happier and gets a little
too fondly I'm dead serious and and he
continues and she goes stop it and and
and you almost feel like she's being
creeped out but I flew this she's like
stop it he's like no I'm serious
I've got the clip I'd like to show you
yeah let's watch it and then at the end
of the clip the kids are eating the
barbecue and he comes and takes it away
from them real fast implying that
they're that it is not a joke and so
here let me let me I mean this [ __ ] is
unbelievable it really is truly
something be Bill Cosby special Biba Q
saw so wonder if he was this is
definitely anecdotal from his real life
outside the show watch his face after
when it kicks in they get all she's like
Thunder hitter
I got a cup of it I said you see that
breathing right now oh my god what's
that isn't that [ __ ] insane weird I
mean wow how is that like family content
you know I think it was just like wacky
at the time but that the actual insignia
context well even the context at the
time is that he's put a drug in the bar
I mean there's no other way to they
haven't worked anything out for
themselves it's all my barbecue sauce
he's seen oh stop it
oh I'm stopping anything in fact I got a
big bucket of barbecue sauce in the room
are you coming up or do I have to force
you and so somebody of course I'm some
genius his name is yet God made a edit
that I'd like to share with you guys
that really captures the moment more
accurately I would say
it certainly is nice to see them work
things out for themselves pick up the
laugh track for them so it's frankly not
disturbing it's a threat
look how we look at his body like yeah
I've got a cup of it I saw this was a
scene for like a horror it worries like
a serial killer or something yeah I
would be surprised if I played this in
court during his trial yo we got a sound
bite the lawyer said like you know in
every joke there's a little bit of truth
right exactly yeah I think that's a good
legal argument yeah we got a sound bite
some of these barbecue sauce clips I
feel like these have perpetual use I
[Music]
love this barbecue sauce
[Music]
Laura we're I'm telling you that what is
this Chris yes that was courtesy of heat
God actually you know what I don't know
how long the stores been uh been in the
news but this is eight years old
sorry I'm literally dyslexic out
dyslexia doubt three years old actually
you know what I did
I cut the eight in half in my mind
because it's three half of eight like
literally if you cut it in half you see
a three yeah
so you completed the three I completed
the three in my mind I know it's really
incredible stuff is it not pretty nuts
you know I'm gonna say this to you
whenever I want to get it on no you're
not you're like the barbecue sauce I
said why don't you go on upstairs cream
you know barbecue sauce so I said it's a
new meaning of lube it up you know you
want to go on it's all the sauce you
seen feeling a little sleepy a little uh
unconscious a little uh amnesia you're
it's all on the sauce play some creepy
music guys but yeah it's all in the
sauce you seen you know you feeling a
little sleepy a little amnesia gonna lay
down close your eyes forget it all
happen you're kidding right on the sauce
oh no no Tom the sauce I guess we have
no creepy music oh
I feel like the moments gone good enough
all the sauce welcome to Papa's house
yeah that's a man that knows how to saw
some pie all in the sauce for him till
now let's all give praise by the way to
Hannibal Buress whoo yeah whoo by the
way let's all remember that Hannibal did
this explosive standup several years ago
somebody just filmed it on our own
everything right
it wasn't on Comedy Central or anything
he was just at a nightclub and somebody
filmed it on the phone and put it online
and it made headlines because built
because Hannibal was like [ __ ] Bill
Cosby always tell him black people what
to do from like I from like up yeah Pat
is still always being like what black
people need the bootstrap themselves up
like me he's like he's a [ __ ] rapist
yeah that was the first time I I never I
didn't know though he was like seriously
go Google Bill Cosby Reagan's and see
what you find and that was the catalyst
that started this whole thing here let's
watch that that would also start me too
anyway probably I think I mean that was
really a prolific not prolific but it
was a monumental it may have yeah yeah
Hannibal
[Music]
you have a great women Gaza yeah that's
crazy that he broke that and a great
joke too but yeah shocking at the time
people of wives
well that's a ballsy claim to make about
anyone publicly to be like oh yeah but
you great people it's like what can't
really say that wow that's incredible
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay this one stand up yeah and yeah
that's really incredible stuff so shout
out the aníbal goddamn well let's throw
it to a break we will be right back
after these messages from me out of my
mouth
aunt from the sponsors on a paper
through my mouth to you
we keep them fresh we keep them funny we
keep them exciting so you're not going
to want to skip it because it's really
fun and exciting really entertaining
copy reads we'll be back after that to
talk about Drake creeping on Millie
Bobbie Brown some Papa John updates and
so much more so please stay with us on
the h3 podcast fully enlightened shade
experience
thank you to kaptara for sponsoring us
we're all bound to face unexpected
hurdles at work don't let finding the
right software be one of them 2019 is
quickly approaching and you do not have
time for unexpected hurdles to derail
you all right captain is a website that
organizes all the software you need to
get the job done they got a free ebook
for you called the big book of free
software would you Ben download for free
at kaptara down slash h3 cap tear comb
is a free resource to help you find the
software you need for your business and
with helpful information on over 300
different software tools there big book
free software I set big you look really
big can help you find a completely free
tool to test today and it's absolutely
free so you won't have to ask your boss
for a penny I can tell you right now
these guys ask me for a penny F no I say
go to kaptara
it's free their day you to ask me for
money yeah
Ian's a good kid I like whether you're
looking for a new project management
tool recruiting soft warning email
marketing solution cap tears big book of
free software has got something for you
visit kaptara com / h3 today to get your
free copy of the big book of software
that's kaptara Capt er a.com slash h3
kaptara coms like Ashley now many people
say that Jesus was nailed at the cross
but actually he was never nailed to the
cross that's revising of history what he
was nailed to was the forum because it
is that profound people think that even
for the cross and suffering and pain but
actually the truth was that he took the
two quips apart and dual brushed his
mouth up to heaven an eternal bliss
because this is the best toothbrush you
will ever put in your mouth now here's
the deal it vibrates it tells you when
to switch sides it helps you keep your
dirty disgusting mouth kissable and
fresh and clean take it from me I went
to the dentist for cleaning in the first
time in three years I said dentist I
come out of here everytime clean as a
whistle he looked at me in the eyes he
says well let's see check check check
and he fists bumped me the dentist fist
bump me because my mouth is that clean I
can endorse this product this is only
toothbrush I'll use it's got the softest
bristles in the game it's a lecture to
make sure you get the best brush
possible I keeps track I mean what more
do you need to say I endorsed this
product I love this product and it can
be yours right now for just $25 you go
try to buy an electric toothbrush at
this caliber for $25 get out of town
you're not gonna find it for less than
$2,000 that's an exaggeration but
they're very expensive go to get quick
dot-com / h3 right now and get your
first refill pack free of a quick
electric toothbrush that's your first
refill pack free at get clip comm / h3
GE t qu IP dot-com / kobe h3 no copy
nope
obviously it's just get equipped comm /
h3 you guys know that i love me undies
because it is the softest most luxurious
underwear on the market today you're
using those nasty old cotton underwear
that you've been using for 10 years that
your parents bought you when you went
off to college and you saw them I got
new underwear well now is the time let
me show you how comfortable me undies is
this whole time I've been sitting having
a mega wedgie sitting comfortably with
this shove up my balls and my ass and
that's how soft and luxurious and
flexible and breathable it is that I
could sit here during a mega wedgie and
not even you know cover your breasts no
yes I can you know I mean I'm fine with
that so that's a real-time demonstration
and I don't think you need any I think
the coffee speaks for it I don't need to
say anything else but I will cuz they're
gonna make they make me do that
membership they've got a new membership
plan guys members pay less for
everything on the Mandie's website and
special member pression that means if
you want a second pair me undies a
bralette
or lounge pants you'll pay less than any
one membership comes with no strings
attached
you can switch styles skip the month or
cancel anytime guys you know I love
these underwear they come with a 100%
satisfaction guarantee so if you don't
love them you send them back they
incinerate them and you get a full
refund guys as simple as that we've got
an offer for our listeners Mandy's got a
great offer for first-time purchasers
when you purchase any me on these you
get 15% off and free shipping as a
no-brainer folks get 15% off a pair of
the most comfortable underwear you'll
ever give yourself an atomic wedgie all
the way up to your nipples folks that's
right do you get 15% off your first pair
free shipping and one
90% satisfaction guaranteed go to me on
DS dot-com /h three folks that is me on
DS dot-com
it's allow h3 welcome back guys thanks
for sticking around I hope you had a
great time during that commercial break
which we try our best to keep fresh and
exciting every time by the way what do
you guys think of a little preview of -
the new hoodie this is part of the
winter collection right next year oh
this is next year we're going on
2019 wait I thought well at any rate new
logo the tf3 yeah let me actually let me
know what you guys think about it
I [ __ ] love this and this is amazing
we have a new manufacturer who's like
crushing it what this stuff I'm I'm I
love it I love it yes ela Rock he was
been working super hard on all this
stuff and it's really nice to see it all
coming to fruition you have to work like
a year ahead of time yeah and that's
like impossible so we're trying to catch
up now right so we're trying to work all
on all 2019 yeah and it's like how it
were well the ideal plan now for next
winter yeah I know it's crazy thing but
I want you've been working so hard you
and and Eva works closely with - we have
- Teddy fresh employees that are and
they're really having a great thing and
I mean this I love this and I love the
new logo we worked really hard trying to
concept some new logos we wanted like a
like a strong branding element that
wasn't a teddy bear yeah amazing I
wanted to not always have to use the
teddy bear and have something more
graphic right like yeah yeah you've got
to it's like you got it but that I don't
know this is a home run
and I love how the um the hoodie has
like the inverted colors and lay is
different color so cool
are you also wearing our shorts oh yeah
Ethan
Drake 31 years old
hip-hop mega superstar Drake milli Bobby
Brown yeah 11 really famous 11 from
strands of things 14 years old it turns
out that they are
I don't not know really not um they're
not wrens yeah and I find it interesting
not only you know yeah well and for good
reason I think because I find it now
first of all now it's speaking as a 33
year old band I'm close to Drake an age
how old is he 31 okay now what purpose
what value would you get out of texting
a 14 year old girl I'm not really sure
not much I'm not really sure I know I
can't say but then when when she goes on
to describe their relationship I not
only raised one eyebrow I raised both of
my eyebrows at first I heard about it
because I think he invited her to a show
and there was like a picture of them
together and it was all cool it was
cleared that he's a fan of her yeah
which you know who is not like it she's
like such a badass on the show yes and
she was a fan of him so all good
yeah but then now it's like well she did
these interviews where she's getting
into details of like we text and we
talked and he says that I miss you so
much and I tell him I miss him and I
imagine him him him at home being like
you know and there's another one where
she's like I met him at a hotel I think
we went out for dinner and then we were
hanging out every night for three days
and now we text each other all the time
and we love each other and I'm just like
whoa and he's giving her advice on like
boys and dating yeah and he's just got
to be at home being like all I'm saying
is Drake be careful because Papa's house
not says not we don't need another we
didn't welcome to Papa Sam Papa's house
don't need another inmate let's watch
some of these videos this is the first
video that came out of her talking about
him let me throw this out this is a
little excerpt of the video for you
gosh he's not my crash okay let me get
let say he's like a brother brother
I met Drake in an Australian hotel I was
touring and he was touring too and he I
want to say his managers just came up to
my dad and said trach loves the show
come to a show tonight and I was like oh
my goodness and my dad honestly he was
on t-mobile I was on the French t-mobile
trying to get us Wi-Fi for Australia he
was like I don't know who Drake is I was
like are you joking me Drake he wants to
see me and I was like okay we're going
so I like got my outfit prepared it went
there and and he was such a fanboy and I
was such a fangirl that we honestly we
text all the time now he helps me with
everything like just life lessons he's
amazing he's a great human being and we
went to dinner afterwards and we had
dinner the next day and then we met in
Sydney hotline bling' is one of my
favorites or the part where she goes we
met for dinner and then we kept meeting
for dinner texting all the time texting
all the time I mean again it's just I
feel like from her perspective I see why
she doesn't think it's weird you know
girl yeah and she thinks she's a dolt
like you know at that like I know
everything at 14 yeah and she definitely
has that err she's a sweet girl she's
amazing but you can tell she thinks well
she's very mature 14 year old too yeah
but being 30 years old being 31 and from
our perspective it looks really weird
I spend closer in age to 3
do you love me are you writing do you
have a cell next to Cosby do you love me
yeah and so anyway that's part one okay
that's fine
Kiki are you fourteen do you love me do
you have a prison cell next to Cosby
so that's part one welcome to Papa's
house here's part two this one just I
guess what about your relationship with
Drake tell me about that people are such
Stooges these uh red carpet [ __ ]
interviews yeah they like don't bat an
eye and they're like oh yeah tell me
about your relationship with drink tell
me about your friendship how did this
all come about I love him I met him in
Australia and he's honestly so fantastic
and a great friend and a great a great
role model you know we text we just text
each other the other day and he was like
I miss you so much cause we can miss you
more he's coming how innocent and
immature she is burst him you you cannot
as a 31 year old man text a
fourteen-year-old girl that's not
related to you I miss you so much mm-hmm
cannot and the fact that she doesn't
understand that so little that even her
saying that doesn't look weird um no
she's she I think she even made like a
statement about it
really just like you guys can't tell me
who gonna be my friend
sure just stop making it awkward okay
but that's why I'm saying I don't think
she can understand at her age how weird
it is no no yeah I agree yeah I thought
you know yeah what can I say a lot of
people say he's grooming her mm-hmm
that's just such a weird state I don't
know that long-term what is group
basically what it means is that like
he's preparing her or when she turns 18
so that he can legally hit it
that's gonna be apparently four years of
dedication led yeah allegedly he's done
that with a some kind of 16 year old
girl he and was Ian's the keeper of
culture knowledge but I don't want mixed
up but allegedly and this is from a
secondhand report but there was some 60
girl he met when she was 16 and when she
turned 18 they started dating really you
know allegedly and I may be false so
again take everything I say here as pure
fact and not speculate them keke are you
riding are you 14 welcome to Papa's
house the other wrinkle in all of this
is like people are saying he's just
helping her out because he was a child
star - all right okay you know what I
mean that's that's sweet that's a sweet
angle yeah what'd she say let me finish
this scientist I'm definitely gonna go
and see him I'm so excited yeah you and
Drake what advice does he give you like
what is these contributions gonna go
there there's a dam we talked about oh
[ __ ]
why do you gotta go there we always talk
about boy this is like all right here so
she said why you got to make a lovely
friendship your headline you guys are
weird
for real I'm lucky to have people in
business expand yeah she I mean again
like you said she just she yeah like you
said you
you know thank you sweating but that the
child star angle is is a valid defense
you know and I'm not accusing the guy of
anything it's just a lot but you know
but it's hard to explain the him texting
her I miss you very much yeah she's like
and he initiated it she was like he
texted me out of the blue I miss you
very much and I was like I miss you too
I was just reciprocating Kiki are you
fourteen are you riding get some
quaaludes in that jello and let's get
barbecue sauce head on upstairs all
right well there you have it
Drake and Millie Bobby Brown next up
we've got stories for days folks this is
the h3 podcast experience we've got
stories for days we've got the best
stories people there's my Trump
impression now we've got the best
stories people the best okay you come
here once you do a Trump impression this
show is really gone I'm not on ready
size Hill I'm just doing an impression
listen we've got the best stores people
I got the hand motion right we've got
the believe me we've got the best stores
believe me doing a Trump impression is
like there's so many bad ones unlike
mine the handma it's a really fun
impression because of all this this show
has really gone downhill
yeah well along with everything else
believe believe me the h3 podcast
believe me the h3 podcast is the best
okay they've got the best stories the
best people taken from it okay I would
know trust me it's the best was that
good
I mean obviously the voice part is good
Jimmy Fallon's Colbert has by far the
worst
I cannot stand Colbert's the Trump
impression mostly because he thinks it's
so good and he talks so slow
oh I was slow it's like oh my god it's
like dude like I think he talks like
this his interests are good but then the
impressions are so it just slows the
show down
yeah he could he talks like this believe
me
the show is the best I don't know that's
actually the best impression you've done
so far is of Colbert doing Trump yeah my
sleep I just need like three layers of
separation from the source that's good
anyway let's get the [ __ ] on with it
papa yeah is it the house in an effort
to distance themselves dude by the way
Papa John's the company isn't like it so
mutiny I've been watching the show the
profit yeah so the property here this is
gonna make sense in the end
follow with me the profit is this guy
Marcus Lamoni lemonis and he's like this
business guru and what he does is he
goes and invests in company and helps
them become profitable he sees the
potential in them but the business
owners aren't really they're just
[ __ ] dumb
it's like Nathan for you and but real
reality right and the problem is like
usually the the companies have an
interesting product or interesting
market share or something like that that
he can work with but the owner is always
just like just so [ __ ] stupid like
it's really a lot of common-sense stuff
he's like alright so you guys I see you
profited half a million dollars last
year but somehow you still lost $300,000
in debt and the owners like yeah well I
bought a $300,000 truck to help promote
yeah or something like that oh that's a
true that's a real one yeah are there
like he's got this big like truck
staying outside of their office he's
like well it's a half a million dollar
truck I got a big discount on Marcus is
like you gotta sell the truck dude well
I didn't sign up for that a breakdown
yeah I didn't sign up for that or it's
always like man it's always like this is
a really common one he goes and talks to
all the employees and they're all
amazing and super hard-working and there
yeah he's never here he just how ever
comes here the owner he just never comes
here he's not involved at all oh he's
like okay so I need you to come to work
five times a week
oh I did well I did sign up for that
okay it's always the same dumb [ __ ]
funny show well anyway my favorite
episodes is when it becomes a full-on
mutiny and it's so juicy so he comes in
at the request of the owner and the
owner such a buffoon he's so incompetent
that he makes a pact with the employees
and they all turn against the owner who
called him and asked him and then he
gets all defensive because like often
he'll give equity to the employees and
then it's like and then they're always
like you [ __ ] you you're not my boss
anymore son like Nick I hate you they
actually have conversations like that
and it's so good the owner will come in
and he's like I don't like how you doing
this whatever and then the employee who
now has equity will say well you're not
my boss [ __ ] you Marcus comes in he's
like well yeah he's right [ __ ] you you
suck and then they always go like well
it's my company and I'm gonna run it the
way I am and the Marcus is like well you
wrote it the way you are then this
business is gonna be out of you're gonna
be closing the doors in two days because
you don't know how to run a business and
it's so great so that's what's happening
to Papa John there's a full-on mutiny at
Papa John's
he has been outed his face is off all of
the branding remember Papa John built
this company he it is all up its [ __ ]
name right but now it's Steve papa
Steve's house welcome to Papa Steve's
house so they're removing his face even
at the headquarters they're doing a huge
makeover at the headquarters where
they're removing his face off the wall
it's not worth the money they're
spending on all this well they're
betting well they must be hurting okay
they're in like full panic mode and so
they're even gone as far as to remove
the apostrophe from Papa John's Papa
John's international filed paperwork
about the new spelling and brand imagery
with the US
Patent and Trademark Office in late
August removing the possessive
apostrophe and Papa John's would in
theory provide a more distance between
the company and its founder so it
doesn't look like he owns the business
that is the dumbest [ __ ] name
so it's Papa John's wait out and impress
but it doesn't make sense it's an it's a
possessive yes his name is Papa John so
what is the s indicator the basic
grammar that I dunno not grammatically
correct yeah he was she's fluent in
English and knows so anyway the
apostrophe is out the face is out and
they have released this heart-wrenching
really powerful movie no it's not put
this down the Papa John I know and love
by the way they are also removing the
better ingredients better pizza
I read that's a classic whoa you know I
by the way guys it's just not that
[ __ ] serious you're selling pies well
anyway save that because they made this
ad that they posted on their Twitter and
it's like a whole campaign about like
we're so sorry we are so disappointed we
have to do better and it's like the
saddest most emotional [ __ ] ever
and I would like to play that for you
now with your permission actually I
don't need your permission you have no
control over the show but I hope you all
enjoy
so they come compiled a bunch of tweets
that they got you know I wonder if it's
really hurting their business or they or
they're freaking out because they're
getting like social media backlash well
the easiest way is to look at their
stock value Papa Jones I mean people who
looks like their I mean it looks pretty
well actually into the five days is okay
hang on let me open this up so here this
is the one year graph you guys can see
it looks like they took a big hit
recently on the Papa okay let's go to
five years let's just get oh yeah they
took a big hit let's go max here's let's
see the historical data here okay that's
not that helpful let's go five years so
you can see do one year one year yeah
yeah they took a big hit from papa from
Papa John but they're climbing back and
I think yeah I guess see it's hard to
know if it's from their efforts or
people are just over it and they want
people they just want pizza you know but
they're like no it's the apostrophe they
like that apostrophe genius we made a
billion dollars I just looked it up and
I see an article that says it was from
the beginning of August that their sales
overall nationally was down seven
percent okay like I mean that is
significant I mean it's not as much as I
expected no yeah it's not a huge
difference but it's okay superior I
agree just like their pizza anyway here
we go
we heard you Papa John's I am so
disappointed in this company I'll never
order from you again
so it's like all this tweet Papa John's
I'd rather have frozen pizza than racist
pizza they're really owning it like
they're actually like railing the
original Papa because they're being like
we are race we were racist pizza but
that was that guy that was that [ __ ]
guy who made this company that we're all
writing racism is disgusting and I won't
support him delete Papa Joe nice name
remember when we were actually making
progress in civil rights issues you
expected better from Papa John's why is
this why is that the music of like a
suicide prevention
it's like Papa John's the company is on
suicide watch yeah Papa Steve Papa
Steve's on suicide watch you expected
better from Papa John's so did we hmm
what is he make of all this Papa's
sitting at home watching this [ __ ] he
must be furious
yeah Papa's in the house what is Bo
think about this a little too late on
this blaming players for poor sales with
dog whistle racism with a hack move yeah
it's just a bunch of these kind of
tweets
I will not give you any more money I
don't know what they thing will do to
earn my business ever again won't put
another dime into Papa John's okay
they're not supportive company until you
change your policies pitiful look in the
mirror stop the flicking blame and do
better
thank you for your anger there's it's
almost like pathetic how like it's like
stand up for yourself Papa John thank
you for your anger
thank you for your criticism and thank
you for your honesty I'm gonna call the
police I think Papa John's on suicide
watch I'm gonna get an officer over
there to the headquarters maybe they're
not gonna hurt themselves the whole
company the whole company yeah thank you
for your honesty is making us better
just like our pizza better ingredients
better pizzas we already have the best
pizza but your honesty is making us as
people better what did I do
Papa John's saying I'm like John's is my
company I built this company with my own
hands I tossed the dough I made the
ingredients what did I do to deserve
this disrespect from you there's a good
look at my son Bo what is my son ball to
do he was meant to inherit this Empire
pay me with that music you guys for
chrissake
my son Bo was meant to inherit this
Pizza Empire so seriously boat just lost
like everything oh my son Bowie's a good
boy he was meant to inherit this pizza
oh my if you had to deal with he's died
but it was like at least I'm gonna get
this yes is that but now now ball is not
in the house from him Stevie you were my
trusted colleague and now I see you do
not trust you more than anyone about
what you're gonna remove the apostrophe
it's my company it's not but it's in the
name is Papa jack my trusted brother
Stevie Papa I sit at home and I think
about my mistakes I maybe I said the N
word on a conference we've got the best
bits I built it with my hands from the
sauce the sauce alfredo sauce stayin is
that my son afraid of them fritters and
now I'm disgraced in the eyes of the
world the Papa debates are king Papa
John's the NFL doesn't love me the
butter garlic sauce Stevie I love the
butter garlic sauce and now look at me
[Music]
running ads on Twitter they give for
your app never betray the family
I feel for you as the godfather Papa
John and now what do you what's next you
gonna remove the bleats about a god
upside it's not the place to buy without
the garlic's a semi that's myself I know
that you're gonna get rid of the better
beats or the better and gritty of that
is inheritances gun hit me with a pup in
the house
well Columbus has helped I could do that
for hours once I got one of the best
movie ever it is it really is because
you mean it I mean yeah that's really a
controversial statement to about that's
really brave of you to come out and say
that so brave nobody but I'm you act
like you're saying like really the best
not just oh it's the best you know why
it's like is it really the best good I
think it is well I'll tell you why it's
the best and it's simple it's all and
this is why I love Casablanca so much
it's just good acting a good story and
that's it it's pure cinematic beauty
it's beautifully directed acted and
written there's no special effects
there's no gimmicks it's just beautiful
cinema you know and you're sucked in and
every from scene to scene you are fully
engulfed I love the first like 20
minutes of waiting you come to me Stevie
you asked to be is that his name Stevie
Steve Steve you come to me on the day of
my daughter's wedding and you ask can
you be CEO and I say to you Steve Steve
Ricky Steve Richard you what did I do to
deserve this disrespect my son Bo he was
teased off throughout high school he was
meant to have this birthright your Tate
bow never did anything what did my son
ball do he was gonna it was a pizza
prince now he's a pizza peasant you
think bow is gonna be like Michael and
just like ruthlessly take control of the
Papa John's Empire be amazing hmm I want
a three-part trilogy about Papa can you
play that music just love it
The Godfather music yeah I'm over it
kill it I just want to watch The
Godfather now do we watch enough of this
yeah now if you close this definitely I
have some shake my head pray for you
guys to do better moving forward well we
didn't finish it
oh I guess that's it I love how they're
posturing of like war on suicide watch
we don't have any plans or we're not
telling you anything just that we're on
suicide watch yeah there wasn't really a
promise at the end to do better or
anything was there it's just like there
is something what the values you want me
to open this
I hope yeah you got our core values they
linked to this yeah this is it
so you want me to read this here hit me
with the Godfather music I was appointed
the CEO of Papa John's earlier this year
as the new CEO I want to share the
values that will drive the
transformation of Papa John I stated my
career in pizza business 25 years ago
because Pizza brings people together
unlike that piece of [ __ ] Papa John's
who was brought the foundation of
everything we are to the ground I found
a home at Papa John's where people from
all backgrounds works side by side
everything Papa John's is 120,000
corporate and franchise team members
around the world we stand for equity
fairness respect and opportunity our
most important ingredient is people well
they have people in their pizzas that's
kind of a revelation
[Music]
when I became CEO I want to do this in
the godfather voice but it doesn't make
sense that's gonna be too slow when I
became CEO in January Oh bear moment
that is right diversity equity and
inclusion became one of my top
priorities what began began as a
committee of passionate team members has
grown into a company-wide effort to
realize our values he says he says here
wake up when I became CEO diversity
equity inclusion became my top priority
what about selling pies you [ __ ]
idiot are we rot in a are we running the
ACLU or a pizza franchise Christ an
independent cultural audit I along with
Papa John's the leaders visited Atlanta
Los Angeles Dallas yeah yeah yeah yeah
recently Papa's leadership team
completed unconscious bias training wow
that sounds vulgar recently personally
committed to adding more diversity guys
it's [ __ ] pizza just sell some pies
for Christ's sake does anyone care we're
assembling a special advisory group
comprised of nationally respected
diversity equity and inclusion experts
to help guide us it's [ __ ] pie we're
kicking off the development of two key
long-term initiatives Papa John might
minority-owned franchise expansion and
development program the [ __ ] does that
mean they're just given damn Papa really
did a lot of damage now you've just
given away franchises what did I don't I
said the n-word on a conference call and
signed sincerely Steve Richie CEO Bubba
joins this betrayal I will never forget
everyone's like get on with it parent
whatever there you have it a
heart-wrenching this the trilogy where
are we in the trilogy is this part 2 or
part 3
what's a part 2 that's part 2 part 3
falls apart part 3 is gonna suck and
it's gonna be weird the new branding is
gonna be weird and everyone's just gonna
forget about Papa yeah you know the end
of Godfather was like sitting outside
and dies and hey there's like the
laundry's on the line and he's like just
chilling in his backyard retired and
playing with the kids that's what Papa
John Shatner is doing right now not to
have a heart attack and fall over and
[ __ ] die well he'll always have the
pizza mansion yeah what did I do
Kong oh man dude you guys are gonna love
this story this is honestly one of the
best most cold-blooded [ __ ] and
cut-throat things I have ever seen in my
life
this Republican candidate for Congress
I'm trying to think of I have it
backwards
well anyway this guy who's I don't
forget who's party or what that doesn't
really matter but a congressman is
running and his opponent goes to his
family recruits five of his siblings
brothers and sisters and they star in
this hit job commercial against their
brother
they're called the go-go swords and I'm
I'm coining a new phrase right now you
just got go Sarge because I have never
seen it's so cold plotted day you got to
see this it's crazy [ __ ] me
so these are all his siblings just
talking [ __ ] on him and at the end they
do a little dupa dupa twist on you know
sir the congressman isn't doing anything
to help rural America Paul's dab
salutely not working for his district if
they care about health care they care
about their children's health care they
would hold everything your family's
[ __ ] up they care about jobs they
would hold him to account if he actually
cared about people that meal so far it
doesn't say the denote that's waste I
ruined the surprise okay because yeah I
ruined surprise they'll get out of that
field like you like you've actually in
that field all the time oh you caught me
out in the field in nature oh hi there
was just in nature Jennifer Arizona I
bet he'd be fighting for Social Security
for better access to health care I
better he I bet he would be researching
what is the most insightful water policy
so angry in the field the environment of
Arizona sustain itself and be successful
and he's not listening to you and he
doesn't have your interests at heart my
name is Tim Gosar David Gosar grace go
Sir John go some are just and goes are
Jennifer co-star Paul guitars my brother
my brother and I endorse doctor grill
doctor Brill wholeheartedly endorse
started food for Congress is that
[ __ ] cult this guy dr. Brill don't
ever pit me against him dude that guy is
cold wings
dude I don't know what that guy's
technique is but he's up to some fun
like dr. Brill was like I'll make him an
offer he can't what that's dude he got
go sard the first ever Gosar D go
starting when your whole family when all
of your loved ones close to you betray
you
interesting stuff I love the top comment
on the YouTube is the go sort
Thanksgiving this year so every awkward
yeah that's an understatement
seriously someone said this is the new
Game of Thrones Season eight trailer all
this [ __ ] isn't unbelievable like [ __ ]
like even if you hate your brother right
even if you hate your brother your
brother sucks and you disagree with him
politically and he's running for office
I mean really are you gonna go in
feature like five of them not one that's
such a badass like little promotion
video how did they even put how did dr.
[ __ ] evil put that dr. brill how did
they even arrange that right I mean who
came up with it they woke up with a
horse head in their bed and dr. brill
sent them a calling card
I'll make them an offer I can't refuse
listen cuz our family hit me with the
music listen no sauce you're gonna star
in this ad about your brother you may
not like it but you'll understand and
they'll become a time when I will do a
favor for you
it's getting tough to do that if your
throat is saying yeah
your throat is over you might throat is
over that bit yeah
as is everyone listening the comments on
this [ __ ] Gosar man hey how you going
hey gang it's me dr. brill so I'm
running against your brother for
Congress and I was just hoping if you
would all be available to [ __ ]
destroy your brother publicly in my
commercial
I don't you lowly doctor are you a
savage are you guys savages I'm a total
savage you know what I gotta tell you I
don't know anything about the guy
they're [ __ ] on but this dr. Burrell
scares the [ __ ] everything and I'm not
sure I want him in office because that's
the coldest kid I've ever seen in my
life like even if you
and get all those siblings to make a
video about that twist I know and it was
made like artfully right like
Shakespearean hmmm but like even if you
could make this do you really want to be
that guy that like tore the family apart
for a good political ad you know what
I'm saying it's cold I feel I need the
backstory of what's going on in that
either way where is this [ __ ] Arizona
those [ __ ] are in Arizona [ __ ]
I am dr. Brill and if you don't vote for
me I will kill you I'm dr. Brill and I
will kill your whole family
if you do not cast your vote for me this
coming September hi I'm dr. brill the
coldest [ __ ] you've ever seen in
your life
I will I will not hesitate to hit those
drone murder buttons you know there's
like drones and Afghanistan bombing
people and I endorsed this message I
endorsed I'll click those drone murder
buttons so fast that was a huge
controversy when Obama was president
because he had all these drones in
Afghanistan just like dropping bombs all
day huh so he's loved Brill is loving
that I will my name is dr. Brill and I
pledge to drone strike American citizens
in the United States I'm cold-blooded as
it gets
pretty much I am dr. Brill and if you
run against me I will ruin your whole
life and tear your family apart and then
drone strike your house if I'm elected
this guy scares the [ __ ] out of me damn
[ __ ] crazy craziest thing I ever seen
I mean it's like it's unbelievable
anyway what else we got next story is
okay this is a quick one I love this
this right this could only have been
Russia woman buried and Russian
graveyard is given a five foot high
tombstone in the shape of her favorite
iPhone well there you have it folks
apparently that's real I don't believe
it I almost don't believe it but there
you have it only in Russia right only in
Russia
nowhere else could anything like that
happen I mean there you have it rest in
peace there discovered in snow and gone
on the back it even has its like really
realistic yeah didn't everything doesn't
have a case it might have a case on it
yes
there she is crushing it crushing it and
crushing it after life as well it's so
crazy the barcode yeah it's got a
barcode give it a scan I don't know
Russia net yeah this girl's amazing so
that's that Ivan really nothing more
than that I just thought it was
interesting um apparently her father
built the tombstone after her death
dedicated to her that's kind of a loving
act honestly yeah can i play you
something I get this voicemail from the
sake I hate these people they call me
sometimes twice a day and they do this
thing where it doesn't even ring it just
goes straight to voicemail right hold on
let me find this [ __ ] thing and tell
me if you guys have heard this [ __ ]
before I have pre-approve you looks to
be expiring soon actually at the end of
the year
always the same exact message give me a
call we can go over rates in terms that
I have available I can be reached at 860
Road I know chemical or you can simply
call me back on the number that popped
up on your phone
you say they usually go no it's they
usually go ah good news mr. Klein you've
been pre-approved for a million dollars
of credit but it's expiring it's
expiring soon though they swear to God
they've called me a hundred times with
bad news you 1 million leaves do not
call and impersonate me and open a line
of credit in my name why didn't you
check it I don't think they know
anything about me except my name and
number
don't call them guys now I wish that I
hadn't played that what else we got Oh
your mom's house the new Ouija board
this is all you can call me okay to the
dead oh that's funny that's a funny
observation you can like open a chat
chat room after life yeah looking good I
love your tombstone thank you we were
recently featured on Tom and Chris Tom
Segura and Christina P the greatest
married news couple in the tri-state
area better than I Marion - what news
you the Tim and Eric Mannion ah these
guys are so freaking awesome I love them
so much they have a podcast your mom's
house yeah my mom's house that we were
on recently and I had so much fun you
guys should go watch that just want to
give them a shout-out I also want to say
thank you everybody who sent emails to
podcast at h3h3 productions calm I loved
all the submissions all the questions
all the videos all the pictures
everything please keep it coming
podcasts at h3h3 productions calm if you
guys have like reactions suggestions -
that you want to send I love everything
I love it in fact I have got some stuff
that I would love to go over here with
you today
on this one annoying h3 podcast
experience what do we got from ml zing
me my buddy made oh this is a new one
yeah swims a little tricky undersea oh
these are all new ones okay so wait
how's this work then you added this one
at the top I just added like two last
night if you just scroll down a little
bit it'll be all the ones that you okay
I haven't seen these ones yet I don't
want to put them up yet and company did
you know if a goddamn company if how's
it going boss there's a group of people
that don't not for a hundred days plus
the reasons are interesting would like
your perspective from Ghia the nofap is
a community online I have heard of and I
am intrigued by their activities now
these are people that believe that by
not masturbating or looking at
pornography mm-hmm they gain superhuman
powers essentially in fact I pulled up I
was doing some research because I'm
aware of the group but this was one of
the top posts of all time on the nofap
subreddit and so this is what they
outline happens to you when you do not
masturbate over the course of 10 years
my god 10 years not [ __ ] trick in
your own filthy s meet anyway five
minutes wow I'm five minutes your heart
rate will return back to normal okay two
to three days guilt and shame seems like
it is decreasing seven days brain fog
will lift school will get easier for you
14 days pro listen also known as okay
they're getting scientific starts drop
14 to 21 days dopamine sensitivity
increases 30 days craving and flashbacks
will noticeably reduce 30 to 60 days it
becomes rock-solid and confidence keeps
rising 60 days you might stop giving a
[ __ ] what other people think about you
what do you it's like when you buy a
facial lotion or something all the
benefits that they describe like right
everything you wish will help
Diamond water mm-hmm
concede a is considered a full reboot
for most people confidence still rising
150-day symptoms of severe pide
disappear and proven oil tide is but I
like the sound of that two hundred days
I feel like every girl wants to [ __ ] me
and I started reading a Bible this as
far as I can tell isn't a joke this guy
found God after 200 days one year I
don't even know why I was watching porn
a year ago two years now I have a
girlfriend amazing job and I've never
been happier
really dull from not masturbating 10
years my life has just been amazing ever
since I stopped masturbating that's ten
years I think this guy's dead serious
which is kind of funny and a little
pathetic but if I'm speaking frankly
there is an interesting theory and not
masturbating because I do think that
like porn addiction is real and I do
think that like when you look like
looking at porn is really unhealthy
because you do it's like when you look
at porn and you just nut and you finish
real fast it is kind of like a high like
you're you get this like you know if
you're like in a bad mood or where a lot
of guys I think rely on like a clerk a
quick jerk and quick porn watch as like
a treatment to a bad mood a lot of guys
a lot of guys I know I think it's very
common and so they'll watch some porn
they'll jerk one out real quick and
you're like and then you can get on with
your day but there is really I think
something to this idea that like your
dopamine your reward levels and [ __ ] get
all whacked out and it really is like an
addiction and so I do think that there
is probably some good benefits to at
least not looking at porn but I've also
read that masturbating daily for guys is
healthy because it helps prevent
prostate cancer because you're
constantly you know pushing everything
out of your tubes or if you let it sit
there like that's how colon cancer
happens to because they don't the more
you [ __ ] the less likely you are to get
colon cancer because you don't want that
stuff sitting there
for so long it's the same theory with
the nut juice so so I am intrigued but
at the same time I'm sure that it's
probably not that serious are you gonna
know pop I mean I'll go I'll know fat
for like a day I'm already at five
minutes my heart rate feels pretty
normal
guilt and shame definitely that's two to
three days so I've been reached that
lovely but we all get milestones my best
record so far as three hours I don't
know
I'm intrigued by it I'd like to hear
from a know flapper I'd like to take a
call from somebody who who who has gone
a long time without masturbating to kind
of here there you know I heard something
interesting about Mike Tyson when he
used to go box when he was like young
like godlike boxer he would it
masturbate or have sex for like months
leading up to his fight cuz it would get
them all crazy kind of interesting not
since you're saying yeah I'm interested
you know they're called fast Ranaut's
too by the way it's very good that's
what it says in their [ __ ]
description yeah I don't know do any of
you guys back there
are you in any of this into this no
fapping oh definitely not absolutely not
what about Zach and Ian guys it looks
like it's all now back yeah lots of
sheepish nose frequent [ __ ] yes
we all are frequent [ __ ] I
wonder how frequently do you guys
masturbate really like once a day and
Zach and in the end just said he's done
it twice since the show started so no
don't be I wanna I'm genuinely curious
I'm taking a sampler
once every two years every two days
pretty conservative that's conservative
you're a young man you should be jerking
off like five times a day
Zack just turned 21 Ian I want to know
how much Ian masturbates I feel like
he's a sleeper I feel like you asleep I
feel like he jerks like eight times a
day how much be honest forty-eight hour
that's pretty responsible I'm like once
a day I guess when I was younger the
reed days dude when I was younger
there'd be like eight times in a day Wow
not that wasn't like common but some
days it's like your dick actually gets
raw so hurt yeah that's like whoa dude
you need to get a life but you but we've
all been there right nothing better to
do I get why these people I got why
these people like you said you know
intellectually I see that there can be
some benefit to it especially with what
you were saying about you know relaxing
your reward center yeah and well and
when you jerk off in the middle of the
day it can [ __ ] your whole day up you
know what I mean
why because you just get so sleepy and
lazy and then all the sudden you're like
you just have no motivation because you
jerked off in the middle of the day it's
like and you're you know what I mean
it's like what do you where you go from
there take a nap yeah no no no fat
I'm intrigued good question thank you
give for that enlightening vigorous
debate thank you and god bless you next
up from P Leighton I work in the vapor
industry and I always listen your
podcasts while I'm here as a fellow
member of the nation I would love to
hear any commentary you guys have on the
new FDA regulations for vaping products
in regards to packaging and advertising
and the law to ban flavors and the
epidemic of teen vaping sincerely xxx
vape wizard 420 XXX hashtag babe nation
great question
so the f-d-a this is actually quite
interesting and Dan you would know about
this because it affects you directly it
is that the FDA is banning flavored vape
juices because they say it appeals to
kids that is pretty much par for the
course in my fingers I did the same
thing to alcohol and tobacco were they
really restricted how they could market
it because they didn't moment appeal
kids and frankly I do feel like vaping
has let become a really severe gateway
drug I don't know if you want to say
gate I don't know whatever but there I
haven't seen it firsthand but I've heard
that a lot of kids in like middle school
in high school I walk around with these
tiny little vape pens and they're
actually smoking which I find pretty
wild because it's almost like everybody
stops smoking cigarettes they're all
like yeah we all understand it's not
cool it's really bad for you but now
it's almost like there's a new problem
where it's super accessible and
everyone's like oh it's not as bad so
it's okay yeah I think we don't really
know how bad it is yet maybe it's not
that bad maybe it's not maybe it is I
don't know but I think it's probably a
good idea that the I what the [ __ ] do I
know Dan what do you think I mean I'm
really of two minds of it because on the
one hand you know I think it you know
obviously it's bad
I don't know how prevalent it really is
with kids like is it more than when we
were in high school
yeah it's smoking cigarettes it's more
apparently it's it is extremely it's
it's it's like overwhelming from from
what I understand again I'm not so I
mean president that that is that is
probably not good admittedly but is it
I mean banning the flavors is that
really gonna do anything to prevent that
you think it's really about the flavors
like yeah
yeah a unicorn you know what I remember
when I was a kid I would go whenever we
come to La my mom would take me into
this candy store that I loved and the
one candy I would always get I loved it
so much was bubblegum cigarettes
do you believe this might and it was a
gum wrapped in like oh okay yeah and I
had a bunch of powdered sugar so you
could go and it would puff out sugar I
think I know that it was so cool
yeah smoking a cigarette and I think I
and like I forgot that existed and I
used to love it too
yeah I loved it as a kid and looking
back on that it's like whoa that's
pretty [ __ ] up oh that was my favorite
I would go get it and I thought I'm so
cool every time those are bad I barely
remember I'm sure those are banned yeah
yeah I'll uh so I don't know I don't
know what the hell do I know thanks for
the question a half-priced
teddy hopefully doesn't look about Teddy
Fresh doing getting no half off Regulus
yeah half-price teddy hey my name's Josh
I've been a huge fan you guys are the
best
youtube channel best channel on youtube
thank you and you know I mean thank you
so much tell me more
well not the biggest trend I was
wondering if you ever heard of a
movement called stop a douche bag it's a
movement in Russia and which a group of
people stop others from parking in
illegal places such as sidewalks
railroads by approaching them carefully
sometimes they will blow up with huge
amounts of ignorant and other will move
straight to physical violence if they
don't comply then they get a huge
sticker on their windshield they have a
nice amount of subs and was wondering
what you guys think does a solution even
work this is productive or should there
be other actions taken just curious
thank you for the kind words Josh I
believe he had said I know if I can
quote him you are by far the best
channel on YouTube from Josh half-priced
Ted you are by far the best channel on
YouTube he said about us thank you for
that
so let's go actually yeah I do know
about these guys stop a douche bag and
actually pulled up the video and we can
watch it together oh okay
let's have a quick look here yeah so I
mean apparently in Russia it's a little
more like you know medieval like
[ __ ] just you see this [ __ ]
they're crazy
there's traffic and there's lunatics are
just hopping up on the sidewalk it's a
little it's a little more lawless
probably in some places in Russia so
these guys are vigilantes and they're
like this is [ __ ] up Tsar cities are
sidewalk don't you know don't drive on
the sidewalk it's dangerous right so
they call it stop a douche bag and they
were taking vigilante justice into their
own hands just like Batman essentially
can I ask you why you parked your bus on
the sidewalk he says it's a service bus
what the service bus I can't hear you
unfortunately we are waiting for some
people to get on okay could you move
your bus at least you parked right on
the sidewalk people push their shopping
carts here
he doesn't seem to give a [ __ ] you won't
be able to get around there can you move
your truck please thank you and they're
asking the guy and he does so there you
have it
vigilante justice but sometimes the
people are defined and I guess that's
when it gets a little one there's a
Mercedes that's on the sidewalk they
stopped him he said oh the guy says this
won't happen again I'm late I'm sorry
okay back your car please they say
it's almost like to catch a predator
vibe it's like I wonder if they know
these guys in Russia
cuz he's like oh you caught me it will
never happen again I'm gonna pull out no
no back up they're saying you can't
they're not letting him pull out they're
making him back up there you go
all people are equal almost drive back
so they send this guy back the guy knew
what was good for a man let's see if
this guy does this guy is not having it
I could tell you right now like the pass
guy was kind of sheepish he was like
kind of on the road on the sidewalk this
guy is fully occupying the sidewalk
there's a huge line of traffic and this
guy's driving on the sidewalk I'm
running late she says for a friend's
wedding I understand what can you place
back to the roadway guys I need to be at
the river girl station 20 minutes yada
yada it's sidewalk I'm late gyro so
you're on footpath for the blind right
now I do understand but sometimes things
come up she says Oh everyone's been
really polite no oh she went around
there just riding around them oh [ __ ]
are they gonna catch up to her so she
drew oh really
so they're chasing after she went around
him and booked it
oh and so what they do is they have
these giant stickers that probably [ __ ]
their whole week up and I guess what it
says in Russian is I'm a douche bag and
it's this huge sticker the covers the
windshield so they pretty much can't
drive I gotta say they gave them a fair
chance
it's very vigilante justice let's see
how she reacts you take that thing off
they put it on the passenger side they
usually put it over the driver's side I
think let's see here we go we've got
another one
oh there's two there's several do that
whole line good day
stop a douche bag movement here just as
himself could you back out of your car
please
and there's actually a car behind him
stop or I'll put a sticker on your
windshield oh he's he's pulling is he's
driving into them trying to run them
over stop they're staying I'm gonna put
a sticker on your windshield
I'm gonna give you [ __ ] and stick here
now they put it so this guy got it okay
now this is great though these by the
way is this twenty three million views
so they put the sticker over the
passenger side window so there's really
no way for him to drive until he gets
off a driver's ed they try the driver's
side so yeah this guy's totally [ __ ]
so he's getting out of his car now he's
not happy and he's got milk he's got
cargo military pants on he's throwing
his sandals out he's getting ready to
kick some ass in those sandals this
guy's this guy's [ __ ] scaring me
please let me grab the knife oh he's got
a weapon he's got like a nunchuck what
the [ __ ] nunchucks Oh get the [ __ ] out
here ugly [ __ ] where do I go oh
he took his nunchuck and threw it in the
woods because there's like 20 of them oh
man he's trying to get the sticker off
but it's not really coming off man this
guy's days [ __ ] I don't care where I'm
driving and you see my [ __ ] tags this
guy like come off here or something
damn these guys are kind of hardcore I
got to say I know that there's like a
lot of mafia ties in Russia so I these
guys are pretty brave I would say to do
this I mean I don't know much about it I
mean even the regardless wouldn't just
you never know this guy could have a gun
and just or not check in this case yeah
they stood their ground man
and these are these are brave kids I
think these are brave kids doing a
valuable public service that's my take
from this right now and that what the
sticker is a pretty innocent but strong
way of being like [ __ ] you and they also
give every day you're taking it off them
goof off goof the only way but what I
like about them is
they don't immediately throw the sticker
on they say hey we're here to keep peace
on the sidewalk
can you please back up and if they do
they don't [ __ ] with their car yeah so I
think these guys have struck in a good
balance of vigilante justice here he's
saying man that guy's so [ __ ] how was
he gonna drive his whole view is
obstructed and he continues to try to
drive forward oh he's getting more
stickers so he continues to charge i-4
and they're putting more stickers on his
windshield and they're actually slaying
on at the front of the car they have
this guys having a [ __ ] up day oh
there's someone else in the car oh girl
his wife's in the car imagine being that
girl yeah wow this guy this is some [ __ ]
he's getting out he's getting angry now
oh he's throwing punches now they're
throwing punches here we go oh oh man
these vigilante took him out let me help
you up whoa that's a humiliation wow
that was that was amazing the guy came
out threw a punch now they've got this
one huge ass like you know in Rocky they
had like the super like USSR boxer they
got one of these guys he's like the guy
that confronts so this guy came out
threw a punch and I was a Drago yeah
Ivan Drago basically body dropped him
and then he's like here let me help you
up to complete the humiliation well this
guy's days [ __ ] there's three stickers
on his windshield oh holy I wonder who's
I wonder what the police say when they
come oh here's what the sticker says it
says I spit on everyone
I Drive where I want stop a douchebag
that's what it says in Russian wow
that's amazing stuff man
these kids are brave and they're doing
it valued public that's it really cool
cool thank you to Josh who by the way
said you are by far my favorite channel
on YouTube no doubt the Josh Matt
Duncan's won yeah I wasn't sure
look that's alright I'm gonna move on
Matt says there was another bathroom
habit I did that I realized was normal
seven years ago I was talking members of
my tennis team in my freshman year of
college whenever I used a urinal or went
pee I would always whip out my balls
along with my penis to pee I would pull
the waistband under my balls and that
always felt more comfortable and natural
and when I brought it up to my teammates
I realized I was the only one that did
that among the team I was so embarrassed
and I have since changed my habits and I
do not whip out my balls anymore to pee
but I miss it is this normal
do you about your balls to pee or just
your your rod as well I would love your
thoughts well Matt I'm so happy that you
brought this to me because I feel like
here at the h3 podcast we are smashing
taboos we are bringing things out to
light that people don't talk about and
we are normalizing behaviors that are
normal and good and just now before I
get a year now let before I get into
that I want to say that we've converted
a lot of people a lot of people have
been shamed to wiping their ass from the
back which is clownish it's ridiculous
it's not convenient it's not as good a
lot of people have taken the time at
home to sit and cup their balls and
penis in their hand and to scoop under
while sitting comfortably with the other
hand and they found that that's a
superior method now I'm not gonna tell
you right now that the front way is
superior even though you have to be a
[ __ ] caveman to stand up and squat
and reach behind your ass and wipe side
to side to clean your [ __ ] I'm not
gonna tell you that I think once they
found out I'm just what I am saying here
is that I don't think that us front
wipers need to be ostracized I don't
think we need to be outcast and demeaned
because we approach problems differently
now I come to this issue of whipping the
balls out now this sweet young man Matt
was he was a you know he was he was
ridiculed by his teammates mm-hmm
well let me tell you Matt I always take
my balls out
[ __ ] proudly and you know why you
take your balls out Matt
because you're smart and you know what
it what makes sense now if you just take
your dick out you've got nothing to rest
your pants on now you're probably like
me you use a waste yeah it works with
the elastic waist if you're wearing an
elastic waisted pants like I often do
you put the waste under your balls
because if you just take your dick out
you have to hold it looks ridiculous
take a little tic-tac peeking over a
[ __ ] molehill you need to take the
balls out you got to let it all breathe
and that's an important thing I
personally find it superior
now Matt don't let people tell you that
you're not that that's not the right way
to do it because that's just absolute
outright disgusting criminal conspiracy
life it's a deep state line when I won't
stand for you take your balls out along
with your dick and now everyone is homes
you're like oh no I'm gonna try that and
then you're gonna find out oh I like
taking my balls out nothing wrong with
it it's all good guys backstage do you
take your balls out you know what it
kind of depends on on the donkey's yeah
it depends on what you're wearing it's
it's situational highly situated and
others into the mic there you go usually
not there you go in hand
finally never oh well in you don't have
to strike that tone I'm trying to
encourage tone it down right not that
serious in
that's right his balls aren't coming out
yeah they're not coming they're staying
in there thank you Matt for the question
and I wish you all the best in life and
all of your ball whipping out journeys
and finally from cow first of all I want
to say how much I love you guys and
everything you do well thank you very
much cow cow I love you guys and
everything that you do thank you mmm
love to hear that and that through you I
found a ton of other creators in content
that I would never have on my own that
being said I want to ask Ethan kind of a
personal question
how are you capable of confirming and
admitting you were depressed oh I want
to answer this but I feel like it's an
awful way to end the show mm-hmm
we're just having a good time with the
balls out we can do it next time
yeah I'll say that for next time I do
want to answer this he says I'll just
finish currently I'm sort of a social
stigma at my university that depression
is a choice and a sign of weakness and I
know that I'm definitely not happy how
do you detect this and how are you
dealing with it currently if you don't
feel comfortable answering well I do
oh I'll answer I think I can answer
without being like super depressing I
agree when I was in college there was a
really big stigma about being depressed
and I'm sure I was depressed at the time
and I think it's really well I think
it's changed but it's really [ __ ] up
because I remember at my college dorm
there was a sign on the wall with like
Prozac and it was some kind of
insinuation that like if you take it
you're weak or something or now that was
the subtext because it was really like
how [ __ ] up is society that
everybody's taking Prozac right and then
sin uation is like oh you don't need
that [ __ ] I wasn't on anything like that
but I agreed I saw that and I was like
oh yeah everyone's on drug you know
mm-hmm
the idea of treating depression was
something like yeah it's it was very
stigma it was like like I said in our
update video it's not sexy to be
depressed it's like just sad it's
pathetic
it just sounds pathetic
there's two kinds of the posters like
everyone is depressed and then there's
like they're really they're real
depressed and needs treatment mm-hmm and
maybe people just like combine it well
the people who yeah well the people who
everyone gets depressed sometimes yeah
but people who get depressed sometimes
don't understand what it's like to be
depressed for two years yeah so that's
why I think there's a disconnect there
it's just it's a it's a it's just a
disconnect yeah it's a misunderstanding
but be that as it may you know I think
I've been depressed for a really long
time and I remember I oh I always knew
that I had really severe anxiety I mean
I was diagnosed with generalized anxiety
disorder when I went off to college and
it was like really crippling all
throughout college and I had accepted
that I had a problem but I remember the
first time when we were living in Israel
I saw a psychiatrist because of my
anxiety was really bad
or maybe I was I was having some kind of
weird thing and I just wanted to talk to
a therapist and he had said I told ya it
was a therapist and I was talking about
my symptoms and I was like you know I'm
anxious and there's this one thing that
I get all the time that I still get
which is that I get like foggy brain and
I feel like not myself I feel like I'm
having a bad high and I really hate that
feeling
it's awful and then the therapist was
like oh so it sounds like you have
depression and I shocked me I was almost
offended I was like I don't I'm like I
have anxiety not to prep I was actually
genuinely defensive and I was like what
like [ __ ] like [ __ ] you I don't I'm I
have anxiety and my reaction was very
much like like [ __ ] you dude and that
was like that must have been like seven
years ago probably was when we were
living in Ramat Gan mm-hmm
and I've never treated it or anything
like that but I've been like desperate
enough where I was like oh I need some
[ __ ] help and so that's why I want to
talk to that guy and I just remember
being really defensive and that's and
that was so long ago and now it's come
to the point where I've slowly kind of
realized that like my anxiety has given
way it that it's morphed into something
else like in college my anxiety was just
this crippling I don't know well it's
free it's frequent that anxiety and
depression go hand in hand
mm-hmm you know and so yeah the more I
thought about it the more time I had to
accept that I realized that there's
probably at this point more depression
than there is anxiety it's kind of like
I addressed the anxiety because I
accepted that that's what I had until
right but the depression I was so I
didn't want to have it so bad that I
ignored it and never addressed it and so
now I feel like now I'm really accepting
it after looking back and thinking how I
feel I mean look at the just read the
symptoms man for me it's like yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes
like we read this off like if I go there
now but it's so like you know here
this [ __ ] was like [ __ ] 100% yes I'm
just trying to find this list of
symptoms
come on for [ __ ] sake let's see some
signs you might have depression sad
empty anxious helpless worthless or
guilty hopeless irritable less interest
in activities less energetic trouble
concentrating changes in the way you
sleep I sleep great that's not it
everything else though changes in
appetite I'm always hungry aches and
pains not really actually
but everything else like um sad empty
anxious always helpless worth to leak
guilty always like I got to the point
now where I was like I'm really now
decided to like actually treat this
because it's become unbearable for me
recently is that I was I'm like always
at war with myself in my head mm-hmm
like torturing myself like every little
thing like social things past things
things that happened a long time ago
things that happen now on day to day
basis small things like you'll say
something and then your torture my or
I'll do something anything but it's like
I'm always feeling guilty over it just
like the dumbest things like and you
know that but just always that war with
myself in my head
hopeless pessimistic you know yeah
irritable big-time [ __ ] so irritable
and I hate being irritable because you
know like you know that you have you
shouldn't be but you are that's the
worst you just can't help it you just
like [ __ ] everything annoys me but
mm-hm and I don't and I so don't want to
be an [ __ ] I so don't want to be an
[ __ ] right now but I'm just so
irritated negate that and I would feel
that all the time like all the time
every day
so inaudible and it's exhausting for you
mm-hmm
because I'm [ __ ] not that pleasant to
be around most of the time loss of
interest in activities I don't have
hobbies I don't enjoy doing anything I
still love playing video
and for the past years like I didn't
listen to music I don't even enjoy
listening to music less energetic yeah
tired all the time
trouble concentrating it's so hard for
me death to do [ __ ] trouble remembering
details ela to have trouble remembering
details like where's your wallet code oh
yes oh my god oh that would drive me
crazy
Ethan doesn't know the address of his
home well I do just not this no you
don't I do just not the zip well that's
like half of the address nobody what
else do you need to know I don't
understand why people ask for zip codes
anymore here's the [ __ ] address
here's the city you don't need this
maybe I'm irritable too but oh my god
every time anything will ask you what's
her zip code it's like it's your home
address I don't know
overwhelmed to make decisions whether
big or small I mean dude it was like
just I mean I was at the point recently
where was like I cannot continue to live
my life like this I will do anything and
you guys might recall me it's saying
that um I had like this bottle of
antidepressants by my bed for the
longest time because I feel like I
hadn't tried everything first and I feel
like I took 3 months and I actually did
make a lot of positive changes in my
life but I still felt awful mm-hmm I
guess not I I made it pretty good for me
that we made changes the biggest thing
for me was like getting away from social
media from YouTube in it but it's hard
to know sometimes it's like leaving you
too sometimes makes you more anxious
yeah and then everyone else gets upset
and that makes you more anxious and just
so it's hard it's hard to know what is
the right thing for you or whatever but
anyway I've never gone to therapy either
I have my first therapy appointment on
Monday
pretty excited I mean if he's gonna fix
me right I'm like all right you know I I
went to a therapist once through a
Kaiser which is our health care and it
was such an awful experience I never
want to go again I show up
it's like McDonald's therapy I show up
and right out the back
you know you expect that it's always
like tell me about your family where did
you grow up I get to know the guy not
fall so I sit down I swear to god this
what he does he goes all right so what's
wrong but what do you want to talk about
like what what's bothering you what's
wrong I was like whoa like [ __ ] gotta
treat a girl to dinner before you [ __ ]
her you know I was just blown away by
that is that what's bothering you we
have 30 minutes come on honey I got a
lot of patients here it was [ __ ] crazy
I felt so uncomfortable do the whole
thing because I don't know this guy
sounds like uh well we've got a bunch of
ads on my channel that I don't want to
do and I don't feel like making content
but I have these obligations no he's
like so tell me uh how did so how do you
make money on YouTube again what's
[ __ ] awful
I love that that's like a great meme so
tell me what's bothering you what's on
your mind
well my father raped me when I was a kid
and all right well here's what you do
just forget all about that crazy so I'm
going to a private therapist that came
highly recommended from a friend I'm
real excited in Beverly Hills so you
know he's [ __ ] legit yeah but to
answer your original question took a bit
of a tangent here your original question
was how did you confirm and admit you
were depressed well for me it took me a
long time
because I was embarrassed and ashamed
and I felt like people around it's kind
of embarrassing thing
- oh I'm depressed oh I'll get over it I
got an email people just don't
understand I got an email from someone
they're like anyway whatever people
don't understand but to you I would just
ask yourself I mean you clearly are
aware that something's off and you're
not happy there's clearly some aspects
of your life that are you're not happy
with it you're not comfortable with that
you would like to change they're causing
you to feel possibly depressed I would I
would consider looking at these symptoms
because for me it's really she's been
crippling and a large part of the reason
why we've just been gone for so long but
also I'm not you know professional I
can't diagnose you so you should you
should see a therapist I feel like
everyone I know it seems like a luxury
but actually a friend of ours was
telling us like there's there's cheap
what was the name of this place she said
well they have therapy on a sliding
scale so if you're broke you can go see
your therapist for 20 bucks mm-hmm and
also there's there's there's you know
there's ways to figure it out but
ultimately I think it's important for
people to know that you just you don't
have to suffer you don't have to carry
it you got to make the decision that
you're just gonna fight it right you
don't want to be a victim to it so [ __ ]
you no [ __ ] that
mm-hmm it's like you're just wasting
your time on this earth to feeling
miserable and what's the point of that
to do what you can't you know because
there's a lot of people before you that
have dealt with it and gotten out of the
war
and they're really smart and they are
there to help everybody else because it
sucks there to help you therapy because
they're geniuses these therapists they
have studied they have PhDs they have
studied this [ __ ] for decades they know
how the brain works right that's that's
something I'm just a guy I don't know
how the brain works right but they can
get in your head and untangle [ __ ]
mm-hmm
and understand you in ways that you
can't they've got drugs that help ease
the burden while you figure it out you
know you'd have to be miserable oh well
if you already are miserable what do you
have to lose anyway who gives a [ __ ]
mm-hmm it's like at one that's at a
certain point nothing else matters but
getting better because what does it what
does anything matter if you're that
miserable it's just like what else at
that point matters at all except
prioritizing number one yourself and
getting better you can't help anyone
around you can't do anything for
yourself or anyone else until you feel
better so that's my that's my opinion
yeah and depressions on the rise you
know more people are feeling it more
than ever because my theory personally
on that is that the world is
increasingly complex complicated
difficult to find your place in the
world to find a spouse in the world to
find a career to find a purpose to make
money everything is so hard to figure
out that and we carry a lot of stress
and along xiety a lot of bills a lot of
responsibilities narration especially
who can afford a house no [ __ ] buddy
like I think about our situation we are
fortunate enough to have been
able to buy a house but but I know the
feeling from in just a few years ago did
we know no we've worked our life and we
weren't even close
we have we were on we were statistically
anomalous with our like success yeah and
the amount of money that we were able to
make and in a short time from being
successful but we've been like you said
just a couple short years earlier making
like thirty forty thousand dollars with
doing the two of us mm-hmm and that's
important yeah you're like buy a house
never happen so I wonder when we're in
this anomalous like unbelievably lucky
situation how the [ __ ] does anyone else
have a chance but it doesn't but again
that you can be at any station of life
and still life is complicated in this
state and age but the internet with the
cars with bills responsibility you know
I'm more depress now because I feel more
lost in my purpose and like I actually
heard to put really good I don't
remember who said it but it's like when
you have money and like financial safety
all that's left is in your head then I
was talking to you about that when I cuz
I was saying before that you're always
like well if only I could afford that
trip I would be happy but until then I
can't afford it or if I just our or it's
like if only I could afford this house
that would be perfect my thing was like
oh if only I couldn't didn't pay rent if
I had really rent
I'd be set for life so you always have
this like you're chasing a goal if I
then I'll be happy right now I'm not
happy because I can't afford it but you
work towards it and it gives you purpose
mm-hmm yeah but when you can't afford it
and you're still not happy then it's
like what is that thing that will make
me happy yeah but I
but anyway I mean I'm in a rare
situation it's hard to relate to what
I'm going
there but just generally speaking life
is so complicated like think back 50
years people didn't have phones that
have [ __ ] internet they just like
worked on farms I genuinely think that
like if you just woke up at 8 a.m. and
worked on the [ __ ] farm for 8 hours
and went home and ate dinner and chilled
it's like that's simple man there's
nothing to crave mm-hmm but that's you
know that's and I think that like modern
day life really goes against our our
fundamental instincts as animals like
mm-hmm
billions of years of instincts and
expectation of what life is and how to
survive that's what it is right billions
of years of survival instincts have all
the sudden in the past 100 years
completely betrayed us because all the
sudden these survival instincts that
we've inherited over evolution billions
of years are no longer relevant at all
yeah right and that's [ __ ] up so I
think a lot of people have trouble
adjusting it's weird because also you
all of a sudden have a lot of
opportunities the demon before and you
have a lot of you know there's a lot of
good that came with a shirt but it's
also crippling yeah so you know I think
I think that I think it's important to
bear all that in mind that life is
really [ __ ] can be very challenging
and confusing and overwhelming it's like
my God who can balance all those things
when instinctually I just want to go
plant some carrots right or go gather
some berries or some [ __ ] or go kill a
deer and then chill in a tepee you know
so anyway looking forward to the essays
of disapproving my theory but that's
just my thoughts and if you disagree
you're wrong
anyway I hope I wish you all the best
and and yeah you should don't don't be
afraid to seek help and don't feel weak
because you are not alone and
increasingly less alone mm-hmm
you know a hundred years ago was like or
maybe 200 I don't know
thousand years ago you know if I've
heard this and I don't know if it's true
but I've heard this that like in Amish
communities that depression and anxiety
is like completely non-existent don't
you know about the Amish I'm number the
Amish yeah and that that makes sense to
me right because they're fully fulfilled
they have very basic or not basic what
they have very they know what to expect
every day and they're fulfilled every
day and their life is they understand
what it is day to day it's not like you
wait about how many days do you wake up
and you're like like [ __ ] what am what
like what am I gonna do today like you
know anyway that's it
meanwhile Papa's in the backyard and
[Music]
clothes are on the hanging pant on the
rack flapping in the wind
papa clutches his heart play the music
Papa clutches his heart bo is running
around the backyard playing with a paper
airplane and Papa clutches his heart and
now here I die alone the old man with
Norman what no beats or sauce remember
me and bury me in my favorite marinara
bury me in a grave of marinara and my
favorite beats of the meatlovers pizza
bury me with sausage and pepperoni and
remember me fondly and make my tombstone
a giant box of Papa John's with my
betcha proudly from the box before they
removed it with an apostrophe John's as
its my company and I Papa John thank you
everyone for watching and remember
better beat better ingredients better
butter sauce never disrespect family
alfredo sauce and to you ill as leaders
remember me
oh no that falls over and has a heart
attack
it does guys that is the show thank you
for watching the h3 podcast revolution
have just been birthed the new title for
the show experience is no longer
adequate it is a revolution I hope that
you know what it's the h3 podcast uh
what's the phrase the paradigm shift the
h3 paradigm shift revolution I hope your
day has been shifted and a paradigm and
we will see you on Friday as always next
week this is your papa
and chief Ethan Papa John Shatner areevo
saying to you Papa's blessings and I've
happy weekend to all my little pizza
boys all my dough boys all my little
bows out there all my little pizza pie
eatin meat eater loving or not
mmm or not just remember bury me in the
grave of marinara good night and God
does
[Music]
you